this is what you see when you arrived at
the Trafford shopping center its
classical features suggest strength
power and permanence
but today into the company that owns it
went into administration the biggest
corporate casualty so far of the covert
19 locked down into is Britain's biggest
shopping mall owner with 17 centres in
total two and a half thousand people are
employed by the company directly a
further 30,000 are involved in the
company's supply chains and a hundred
thousand work in their tenants stores
making it a significant regional
employer and now a significant regional
problem profit Center is a is a a
destination of national significance of
course any interruptions of businesses
is economically damaging and we would
also be working very hard to support
both those who run the Trafford Centre
and the businesses and who operates
within it but the shopping centers
mainly young retail workforce don't want
reassurances they want jobs I love
working on the Stafford Center like I've
worked here for about a year and a half
and it's just it's just such a nice
place to work always full of like so
many people but can it be sad if we lost
their job as well cuz just all my
friends and everything but I don't know
we're all just kind of helped them for
the best really they've been open for
two weeks now and so we told our closing
down again it's just kind of you just
don't know what's going on you don't
feel like you're just like definitely
now all the time of what's gonna happen
during lock down some really well-known
high street shops close but there was
nothing to match the size and the scale
of the into shopping centres and its
closure would be the starkest warning
yet of the problems to come the retail
sector
into like other retail players had been
struggling for years burdened first by
debt and then the lockdown slow down
it's been extremely complex
administration if you think about what
into does it keeps these shopping
centers open it provides the services
the lighting the cleaning etc so the
suggestion is there's going to need to
be about 12 million pound put on the
table just to keep these shopping
centers alive for now into says its
shopping centers will remain open its
prime retail space could be tempting for
new buyers but in this post covert
climate that's far from certain
katarina vertices Sky News in Greater
Manchester